Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
June 5th, 2017. What's going on? How I, yeah,
how's it going? How was your weekend? Um,
it's really not Monday morning at this point. I mean,
it's still my Monday morning, just 20 to fucking 11,
but by the time I finished this shit's going to be about noon, noon.
I'm Saskatoon seed, the northern lights.
Um, I just had a fucking amazing weekend.
I want to thank everybody who came out to cluster fest up in,
um, San Francisco, this new comedy festival. Um,
I was up there Saturday and on a Sunday.
Um, I had like, I had like a make a wish weekend was crazy.
I went up there. Um, let's see. What did I do?
I did the two dope Queens podcast. Then I did, uh,
I did the comedy jam. Goddamn comedy jam.
We playing outside near City Hall, which I called the fucking state capitol.
Anytime you see a dome, I'm like, that's gotta be the Capitol of the state.
I mean, what, why, why would they spend that much fucking money?
Making something look that impressive. And all it is is just city hall.
You're telling me the fucking mayor lives there. Jesus Christ.
I'd love to see the governor governor's above the mayor, right?
Is that how it works? It's like meter maid, then it goes mayor,
then governor,
then state representative congressman, right. And then a senator.
And then the MotoGP level is you're the fucking, uh, you the president,
alright.
Tweets and gets up and storms out of interviews when he doesn't like the
questions. Um, the fuck is going on with it.
You know, I watched this thing on, uh,
what's his face of Lottie Dottie there Vladimir Putin saying like,
how like anybody who's like an opponent of his, they stay fucking kill them.
There's, they've had all these weird suicides.
So one guy tied himself to a chair and somehow threw himself into a pool.
That one right there is not only,
um, getting rid of your enemy,
but it's also displaying your level of power because when you're not even trying
to hide it like that, oh yeah. That was a suicide. Um,
anyways, and then he's like, poisoning fucking people in all this shit.
Whenever I watched those shit, I'll never watch up. Um,
stories about people like that. There was this guy,
and he's gotten poisoned twice.
First Time you went into a coma for a week and he was in the hospital for like a
fucking month.
Now he walks with like a limp and he went right back to protests and you know,
the current regime in Russia. And then he fucking,
they poisoned him again. He goes to the same hospital. This time they realized,
you know, with his symptoms going right,
this guy's probably been poisoned against.
So they knew something a little better.
So they got them out in like a week to 10 days.
I don't know about you guys the first time I get poisoned and I, and I live,
I'm going to say to the cause, listen guys, I'm passing the torch. Okay?
I did my part. I'm going to, uh,
I'm going to start making those furry Russian hats.
I'm going to open a little fucking kiosk down at the local, um,
people's mall, whatever the fuck it is. It's, you know, it's funny,
as everybody thinks Russia's communists, right?
Somebody told me that the other day going like that dude,
they haven't been communists for like fucking 25 years. They're like over here.
It's like a small group of people running shit except a a, you know,
rather than tweeting and walking out on shit, they just kind of poison people.
They've taken it to the next level.
I believe that kids say it's turnt up. Um, but anyways,
cluster fest, I just,
I went to bed watching that as I started talking about a comedy festival and
then I go over talking about a guy getting poisoned and continuing to do what
the fuck if he ever got poisoned doing stand up. That's it. I'm done.
I'm done. I would just,
I would send out a tweet, uh, to whom,
whoever poisoned me, uh,
what would you like me to be doing with my life so I can get on with that.
Um, stock stock room at best buy. You got it. I'll fucking load.
And unload flatscreen TVs for the rest of my fucking life.
To not go into another week long coma and stay in the hospital for God damn
month. Knowing that there's people out there that not only can poison me,
I don't know who the fuck they are. And when they did it,
it was just sitting there talking to his wife.
Everything's fine and out of fucking nowhere he see you went from feeling all of
a sudden, hey, you know, I feel a little at, is it hot in here? Boom,
right into a coma to fucking 20 minutes later
continues to fight the good fight. Man, that's amazing.
That's amazing. You know, if there is an afterlife for whatever,
I feel like that guys in the pre-checked TSA line, you know,
just goes right through. Um,
I saw this little youtube video on this guy who allegedly had a 200 IQ and I
guess the average person has a hundred you get up to about one 31 40.
You're a fucking genius. You know,
fucking Tesla had a one 50 fucking Galileo and a one 60.
Somebody had a one 90 and this guy's got a 200 so he's allegedly the smartest
person on the fucking planet and he lives in the fucking middle of nowhere and a
Goddamn farm with like a couple of yaks and some chickens.
Then he met some other super genius woman out of Brooklyn. Um,
I don't know if you heard them both talk. I didn't buy it.
I didn't buy it first. I Dunno what's his wife started talking and it's just,
they never really made him demonstrate how fucking smart he was.
He just was talking about what he was doing.
He was trying to prove that heaven exists. So
yes,
right there. That was suspect to me once, just kind of like going like,
all right,
this guy is like the smartest person ever and he's like a fucking religious
freak,
you know?
I don't know. That's always a, uh,
I haven't found too many smart people that are like that level
into religion. I have found smart people into religion,
but they're kind of like, hey, this is what I believe. You don't believe it.
I get it. But you know, it works for me. So while I have a nice day,
they supposed to tell you you're going to fucking burn forever or some shit.
I Dunno, like always trying to prove the existence they have.
What about hell does that exist?
Okay.
I don't fucking know. Um, I'll, I'll send a, uh,
I'll post it. Is that what I'm supposed to say? I'll post the fucking clip. Um,
anyways, let me get back to cluster. I'm fucking talking in circles here. Um,
so yeah. So I landed, I did a private gig and then I did two broke girls.
Then I played drums at the goddamn comedy jam outside the fucking Mayor's house
in this giant square. There was a couple thousand people there.
Um,
and I forgot to adjust this one symbol. So I tell him to bring my stick up.
This my, he had like the fucking crash symbol. The other drummer,
we had the crashed symbol, nick right above it.
And I kept hitting it and I was mission shit. I was fucking up,
but I just kept going. It's kind of a learning experience.
Like I fucked up a lot. I thought and uh,
but I just kept going and somehow landed on its feet.
And then later on that night I did a show there.
I don't know how many fucking people were there. It was freezing.
It was the coldest I've ever been doing standup up. It just like outside,
you know, safe for those people who don't live in San Francisco.
And I've made this mistake because I took a vacation there a long time ago in
July and I dressed like it was July. Um,
San Francisco summer I believe is like end of September to like middle of
October. It's really quick
and the rest of the time it is fucking freezing. So,
um, I was in this little fucking trailer in the back,
which always cracks me up about this business. You know, you're like,
I'm going to make it some day. I'm going to be a star.
And you end up in a fucking trailer park for most of your career.
So I'm in this trailer, right? Not even a double wide.
I'm fucking sitting there and oh, by the way,
Les Claypool Band played across the way before I went up.
So I got to hear them play. I couldn't see him play,
but I got to meet him briefly. This is my make-a-wish weekend.
I just fucking broke out the double pedal and I've been trying to play a Tommy
the cat and that type of shit, which I'm failing miserably at.
And here I am meeting the fucking guy that wrote the Goddamn Song.
He was cool as hell. His band sounded amazing. Um,
and uh, yeah, so I was standing down and I did a show. It was me,
Joe de Rosa and Pete Davidson and I was sitting in the trailer trying to get
warm, um, you know,
learning from the east coast going right.
If I'm already cold with my hoodie and my jacket on,
I need to take this shit off and let my body adjusts. So when I go out there,
when I put the Hoodie jacket on, I'll LBR right. That's something, um,
you learn as a kid.
If you already put all your snow shit on inside the house and your body adjust
to your temperature in the house with that shit on,
you can then go outside and you're going to be freezing cold. I don't know.
Well how it works. That's how it works. You gotta take your fucking jacket off.
So I was doing that and as I'm doing it,
I'm listening to Rosa and he's murdering in like the laughs he's getting is not
opening a show. Laughs. And he went out there at like, no pun intended, cold.
There was no nothing, no music. I don't even,
what the fuck it was just ladies and gentlemen, Jonah rose on,
he walked out to the parking lot where the hell we were performing and he was
getting laughs that were not open or laughs.
And then he brought up up Pete Davidson and he's fucking killing justice hard.
Both of them absolutely murdered. Whoever was at the show,
I know can back me up on that. And
then I went out there and it was a,
it was one of the more memorable shows I've had with like the a,
the mayor's house there. They had the dome,
it was all lit up and like this Celtic screen, which was pretty cool. And, um,
where they'd sat everybody,
they would like these traffic lights that would tell him butyl walk or not walk.
And I kept, you know, was seeing the sign when they were counting down,
whether it was safe to walk across the alleged traffic that was no longer there.
I kept thinking that was like the end of my set. It was like fucking me up.
And whenever the red light came on, I'm like, does that mean to wrap it up?
I kept it until it's a fucking traffic. Like mmm. I Dunno. Anyways,
so I did that. And then on Sunday, no, and then I went to a big after party.
You got to hang out with Derosa big Jay, Nate bar, gutsy,
all these fucking guys, man. Just having a great time.
And then the next day I got to interview Jerry Seinfeld, um,
promoting his comedians in cars,
getting coffee that's going to be out on Netflix. And um,
I can't even tell you how fucking nervous I was to do that cause I was just
like, all right, I was joking in the interview going like,
I always feel like I'm one dumb comment away from you just standing up and just
walking out of the room and I never see you again. Like that's the vibe he has.
And as I said that he stood up and just walked out of the,
starts to walk off the stage. Um,
I was like really nervous because I thought that, uh,
I dunno, I just thought he was going to give really quick,
short answers and I was just going to be sitting there like Chris Farley when he
did that sketch, what he ever interviewed a Paul McCartney, like,
remember we did Seinfeld.
That was awesome. Like I thought it was literally going to be that guy, but I'm,
within two seconds I realized I'll wait.
This guy did the tonight show with Johnny Carson. You know,
why wouldn't he come out here and absolutely fucking kill it if he just sat here
giving me quick answers to thing would go nowhere and then he would look bad
with me. Um, it was amazing,
was one of the most fun things I've gotten to do in my career. And um, you know,
before I interviewed him for whatever, I had all these fucking questions.
Like I was going to look at my car, I'd never interviewed somebody like that.
So I had all these questions I was going to ask him, you know,
he's favorite car of all time, his favorite met of all time, you know,
what level dictator would you still be willing to do a private show for?
You know what I mean? Um, and I never even had to look at them.
Nice. A few of those, I think I asked him who his favorite met was.
I forget who he said it was someone from like the 69 series, but um,
it's probably that guy that dove caught the ball. Um,
but before I went and interviewed them, I was looking up, you know,
some information about them. Just so I would have something.
I was trying to think what the fuck.
And I asked this guy that he's not been asked a million times before,
and I just happened to seats as Jerry Seinfeld comments on Kathy Griffin, um,
controversy. And they cut to him. They were just like, Jerry,
what do you think about the whole Kathy Griffin, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah,
blah, blah. And he just goes, it's stupid. Who Cares?
That was it. And I was like, oh my God,
is he going to do that when I interview them? Is it going to be that quick? Um,
[inaudible] thank God, thank God he didn't. Um, thank God he didn't.
So it went great. Thank Christ. And then I,
um, the interview ended, um,
I dunno. We would just say, man, that was a lot of fun. That went great.
It was awesome. And then he left, and then me and Josh,
Adam Maya's jumped in a car. It didn't really jump in a car.
Jerry jumped in his car because he does life. Right. You know,
he gave me some great advice about being on the road. He said,
when the show's over, you just go and go back to the room.
Egos go back to the room and I go, you ever just want to go out and have a cup?
He goes, go back to the room, goes, there's nothing,
nothing good is out there.
Just go back to the room and do you know I already knew that d not many times
I've learned that fucking lesson. And he said to me, he goes,
if you want to look this good in your sixties,
go back to the room and he looks fucking great.
So I'm gonna try to do that.
Okay.
How do you go back to the room? You don't go back to the room.
You have no stories.
Okay,
I'm going to be in Montreal this weekend. How do I go back to the room?
One of my favorites to Gab buys in the fucking world is there.
How do I go back to the room?
I'm going to have to tell you every time I go back to the room, um,
I'm hating it right until I get to the elevator.
And then I go up in the elevator and I go into the room and I put the TV on and
the second I get into the bed, I'm like, oh my God, this is awesome.
This is fucking great. I don't know why. I just,
you know, I think I finished the show. I'm wired, I'm excited.
It went well. And then I, you know, I go on the road with friends. Yeah.
And they're always, what do you think? Uh, maybe go have a couple to a tree.
And I always say yes.
Okay.
I always say yes. So anyways, so the show ends.
I've learned to go back to the room.
I've also learned to have the car service right fucking there.
Like Jerry, it was just, it just, just like his act,
there was no fat on him fucking leaving the stage, going to the dressing room,
getting his shit. And he just walked right out and I said, I go, yeah,
of course. I go, look it, look, this is how you do your life.
The fucking cars ready. My guys, I don't know where the fuck he is.
And he just laughed. And he just got in his car and it was over. So
I usually don't have any sort of a car service. I usually just walk out. Okay.
So the reason why I have a car service was because I had tickets to go to the
game, to the NBA finals.
My make a wish weekend continues.
So my car guy goes, yeah, I'm Fuckin Dude,
I'm fucking deaf. The street and the car garage. And I go, all right,
so we're right here. I told them where we're at. Come to the stage door.
The dude comes to the stage door on foot
and walked us back to the fucking cock.
The show ended at three 45 to final started at five o'clock so I'm like,
what the fuck man? So we walked all the way over to this parking garage.
[inaudible] got in the elevator, went downstairs. I'm like,
I'm in the parking garage with the crowd.
It's the most anti showbusiness thing ever. It's the most anti Elvis left.
The fucking building was fucking pedestrian was shameful.
I should've had my a year in show business card revoked.
So we get in the car and was sitting in the traffic with the fucking crowd to
get out of the parking garage. Nothing VIP about a complete fucking moron.
I am. So we ended up, uh,
me and Josh were riding in the car over and we're just laughing. Go Dude,
we're going to the fucking NBA finals final. So would ever the fuck you saying.
And um,
and we had a couple of cigars and we said to the guy who turned out to be the
greatest driver ever, we were like, dude, is it okay if, uh,
I don't get the guy in trouble.
He may or may not allegedly have let us smoke the cigar in the back of the car.
And, um, we ended up getting to the finals and, uh,
we missed about half of the first quarter.
And it's just one of those things like,
I can't believe I'm here and I love that fucking arena.
It's gonna be a shame when they leave it.
I'm going to tell warrior fans right now, enjoy that arena.
Cause your next arena is not going to be that loud.
The new ones that never that loud,
because they build in all of those luxury boxes and everything is just so
fucking big and far away from the court. Um, but anyways,
so we go to the game and we're watching the game and it's fucking, you know,
it's great through about the first two and a half quarters and then the worry is
just start pulling away.
And I gotta tell you as a fan of sport and competition that Kevin Duran,
the allowing Kevin Duran to go to the warriors was,
that's out of all those things. Lebron going to Miami,
a fucking Kevin Garnett and Ray Allen going to the Celtics,
Shaq and Phil Jackson go into the Lakers.
This one might be the worst one because at least like,
like Shaq and Phil Jackson, that was a bad time. But still,
you still had like the Spurs, they attempt Duncan, they had David Robinson,
you know, you still had something to compete with. And um,
okay.
You know, with the Celtics, when we won,
we still the beat the fucking Lakers and God knows they always had 9 million
fucking free agents.
And even the fucking heat that first year they lost to the mavericks.
But this one, it was just like, I'm trying to think of an analogy to compete.
Be like if Matt Magic Johnson joined the, uh,
the Celtics or Larry Bird joined the Lakers after the 1985 championship.
When we lost him in the finals, he just joined the fucking Lakers. Um,
I got go. Yeah.
It just felt it felt fucking dirty when I was watching it going like,
this just doesn't feel good. It just, I dunno,
I wasn't an NBA final game and I was actually bored,
which is funny because I, I thought when I was at home,
I didn't know what the warrior fans were chanting when they were saying
Warriors, warriors. I thought they were chanting boring,
boring.
I literally thought that that's what they were saying because there was so much
look at last years Western Conference finals that was fucking unbelievable.
That seven game series with the thunder and the warriors.
And then you look at last year's NBA final was fucking amazing when seven games
and was won in the last second by the Cavaliers. It was incredible basketball,
incredible level of competition. It was amazing.
And then, I don't know,
I don't understand how the Chris Paul trade was bad for basketball,
but Kevin Duran go into the warriors
and then just watching him puffing their chest out and punching it fucking chest
and, and the crowd going crazy as if they don't realize what they're watching.
Okay.
Like acting as though like, yeah, man,
this year's our last year you beat us. But you know what, we dug down deeper.
No, you didn't. You didn't.
Okay.
You picked up the best guy that almost fucking beat your last year and added a t
a team. It was like, I don't know,
every time they get to within three to five points, what's, I have to tell you,
it's pretty fucking amazing when you're playing a team.
They haven't even lost the game yet. They've lost one game since February.
Um,
and they were already playing like that before they had Kevin Durant.
So I'm not trying to rain on people's parade here or anything, but,
uh, I really don't have anything to say about the game other than I will for me.
I watch sports to watch competition.
I don't watch it to watch a layup. Um,
I mean the fact that they have all of those guys and then they can rotate them
out and when they, Lebron is sitting down,
they got another two Lebron still out there. It's just fucking,
I dunno, there was a lot, I don't know. There was a lot of like,
I just couldn't believe I didn't hear one warrior fan address it. You know,
at some point just kind of be like, if yes, it's kind of a,
I mean, any Celtic fans out there, you didn't feel like, dude, what the fuck?
That year in 2000 we were like in last place and then Kevin McHale's in the
front office of the Timberwolves and trades away Kevin Garnett for nothing.
A former Celtic does that to the Timberwolves like that should have been
investigated the same way. The power is salt trade when, what's his face?
Jerry West was in the front office of the Grizzlies. Yeah.
We'll give you pau Gasol for his fucking brother who's now good.
But he wasn't back then, was a horrible fucking trade. Um,
those were bad enough, but I think this is the worst one ever. Like this is, um,
I'm still holding out. I have to root for the Cavaliers.
I'm still rooting for the fact that they can somehow, uh,
you know,
obviously they've got to win the next one most obvious fucking statement ever.
But um, yeah,
I got to tell you from about halfway through the third coordinate started
pulling away and then the Cavaliers kept fighting back and they just had,
it was, it was ridiculous. It was like, I don't know,
I just walked out of there going like,
that felt like a fucking regular season game. I didn't feel like, I dunno.
I Dunno.
I don't know how the fuck
somebody explained to me what that that's competition. Like as a warrior fan,
you're going to look at that and just be like, yeah, man, that feels good.
And you have to be honest with yourself. Warrior fans,
weren't you guys bitching at Lebron when he went to Miami and he won two down
there, right once say, and that's fucking bullshit.
And to pile on team now. Now if you were,
you got to say that about your own fucking team and I didn't eat that once.
I just saw everybody fucking walking around thumping their chest like this was
the greatest fucking thing ever. You know what else is funny too,
I really think is hilarious is um,
when the little kids come out and they do their dance routines,
that aggressive hip hop dancing, it's the funniest shit ever to me.
Like what dancing has become.
It's like you're literally sitting there like when like a little kid dance when
I was a kid, it was cute. It was adorable. Now you just sitting there like this,
does this kid want to fight me?
I think his six year old is squaring off with me.
This whole fucking new generation where everybody's just walking around like
they're these gods.
I don't know what the fuck that is about these fucking Instagram douchebags who
are trying to be inspirational people is they're showing off their fucking abs
like, like they're trying to help you by showing off their beauty and their own
success and standing in front of private jets, holding up a water cash.
I just, I for the fucking life of me,
I can't understand why that behavior isn't ridiculed and why it's actually like
aspired to.
Okay,
go out and get yours.
So fucking get what?
A bunch of fucking shoes. I Dunno. Oh God. I'm just a crabby old man.
I have to tell you. Um,
if the Cleveland Cavaliers and somehow signed a giant free agent at the level of
Kevin Durant,
then I think this would be probably the greatest NBA finals ever.
Cause it would be like two hall of fame fucking teams
going at it with each other. Um,
and then even if I, you know, I always hated that fucking,
you know, I, I hate the super teams as you can obviously tell,
but at least if you have two of them going at it, then it becomes interesting.
Like back in the day when the, uh, roided up free agent,
red sox went up against the roided up free agent Yankees.
I know it was bad for baseball, but at least there was, I dunno,
there was another roided up free agency fucking team out there.
This is just like, um, I dunno,
I just don't understand how you play a team that has the talent that Lebron has
and it's like fucking child's plate because you got this other,
this fucking juggernaut you just signed in a, I don't know,
it was weird. It was a weird feeling leaving there. So I think I've, I fucking,
um, I dunno. I think that was a little too long.
I probably talked about it too long, but like,
I was so excited to go to the fucking game and then you just,
it would have been nice if one warrior family like, yeah, you don't,
it's kind of bullshit. But uh, you know, you'll, Brian did in Miami,
so does that kind of make it okay? I mean a, Hey,
you know, that guy touched a kid, so why can't we touch a kid? Right.
Doesn't it? Isn't that how it isn't how it works? Yeah. I was joking with Josh,
I got to that felt dirty
and then I also have to too. I absolutely fucking cannot stand the west coast,
the west coast fucking, um, sports fan. I just cannot stand them.
I did not hear one intelligent thing yelled during the game. I mean their,
their, their commentary is different reads of, Oh shit.
Yeah.
Oh that's it. Nobody fucking seems to know what's going on.
There was one guy behind me going, oh,
I never seen the calves come out with this lineup. Oh, they're going big.
There was a couple of people,
but everybody else was just fucking mouth breathers.
Just waiting for the ball to go through the net to be like, oh shit,
they don't want no, no,
I'm sorry it didn't meet the fucking blow tears there. All right. I'm all right.
I'm done fucking whining about that shit. But it is bullshit. It is.
I actually heard, this is what it on this fucking west coast sports fan.
I went into the bathroom and somebody yelled out with two championships going on
three and somebody goes two and a half. We got two and a half.
I don't know if he was saying like they should've got it called a championship
last year or they were already racking this one up. Okay.
Because they already fucking, we're going to win game two. I Dunno.
I don't fucking know. I have no, I have no idea.
I hope that that's what that guy was saying.
Do you think I shit on the whole fucking thing long enough?
I really didn't think it was going to go that long.
I'm already fucking 28 minutes in. Alright,
let's do a little bit of advertising here. Oh, by the way, uh, rest in peace,
blue apron, blue apron decided not to, uh,
continue advertising with me because I said, um, you know,
when they were re I was reading the copy, it says, you know,
when you have fresh ingredients, food tastes better.
And it was like really fresh ingredients taste better.
That's the reason they're claiming that they, they, they stop, um,
wanting to advertise in the podcast.
Not because six weeks ago I read that story where they were, you know,
going to farmer's markets, trying to box out the little man, you know,
I know that's what it was. I know that they just were like, well,
we can't do it now, or he's gonna bring that shit up,
that filthy shit that we allegedly did up again.
So we're just going to wait and we're going to wait for him to do one fucking
read that we don't like and then we're going to be out. Come on. Blue Apron.
How dumb do you think I am? Huh? Stop going down to farm farmer's markets,
allegedly. You know,
do you want John Cougar? Mellencamp do you have to write another fucking song?
Is that what the hell you going after? All right, here's our,
here's our old friends. They don't give a how I read these, these,
I like these guys. This is all zip,
but Curtis, are you hiring? Do you know where to post your job? Well are Ya,
do you know where to post your job to find? You know what?
I got to start this read over again. You know what I was just thinking.
I bet if I turned on ESPN, you turn on ESPN.
You know if and when the warriors, when the championship it,
I bet those fucking guys, they're not going to address it on any level.
They're going to be like, Oh, where do you meet? Gay weighed 60 [inaudible].
Where do you put the at? You'd have various teams of all time.
I mean, even the 96 balls law's two games.
[inaudible]
they're going to do that and they will never address of fucking ridiculous
citizen. How bad for basketball it was. That Duran left the thunder
just to fucking go pile on fucking pile on.
Anyway. Sorry. All Zip recruiter. Are you hiring bull? Are Ya,
is that what you're doing?
Do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
Talk about the challenge of finding great talent and slash or the importance of
finding great talent to succeed to successful business. Oh, I gotta tell you,
you know, when I walked down the street with my sandwich board going,
who's talented? You know, it's really hard and I always think, you know,
I wish there was a better way, you know, because you know, in order to win,
you got to fucking have all the best guys on one team.
So they win by 30 every night. Um, dude,
you realize the fucking Cavaliers scored 63 or 64 points in the first half and
they was still down by five. I mean, what are you going to do?
You scored 64 65 points usually up by 10 or 15.
How ZipRecruiter is different with ZipRecruiter. You can post, um, you know,
it's, and this is what the west coast sports fans just going to say hater.
That's all they got.
I don't know if it's cause they get up three hours later then people on the east
coast, but they, I know they just baked their brains in the sun,
but I don't know they fuck, oh, I'll tell you that rough out here. You know,
how's ZipRecruiter is different with ZipRecruiter.
You can post your job to 100 plus job sites with just one click.
Then their powerful technology efficiently matches the right people to do your
job better than anyone else. That's why
Zip Ricardo is different. Unlike other job sites, sip
doesn't depend on candidates finding you. It finds them. In fact,
over 80% of jobs posted on ZipRecruiter. Get A,
get a qualified candidate in just 24 hours.
No juggling emails or calls to your office.
Simply screen rate and manage candidates all in one place with ZipRecruiter's.
Easy to use dashboard. Find out today why zip.
Okay
has been used by businesses of all sizes to find the most qualified job
candidates and me with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on ZipRecruiter for free. That's right.
Free by just going to
ziprecruiter.com/bird that's ziprecruiter.com/pro one more time for free.
Go to zip
[inaudible] dot com slash [inaudible]
um, all right.
How many more of these fucking things you know I should piss off more people.
I could fly through this part of the podcast. All right, what do we got here?
Oh, dollar shave club. Dollar Shave Club is this smarter choice.
You get a great shave at a great price.
Conveniently delivered right to your door.
Do you want to stop nicking your balls when you shave him?
You no longer have to Schlep to a store to do it.
Buy It cheaper it disposable razor that gave you a cheap shave or spent a
fortune on razors with gimmicky shaving you didn't need.
You don't need to do that shit. And when you use dollar shave clubs,
executive raters razor with their doctor
cabbies. Easy shape.
Okay.
The blade gently glides across giving you the smooth shave,
gently glides over your ball bag down to your taint.
How do you guys shave your balls? Do you go from asshole up to the ball bag?
Do you come up and over the horizon as the Sun rising or setting over your ball
back?
A toxic Dr Carver's shave butter is transparent for a more precise shave,
helps prevent ingrown hairs and fights. Razor bumps.
Make the smarter choice by joining Dollar Shave Club for a limited time.
New members can get their first month of the executive razor with their tube of
Dr KVCC shave butter only for $5 with free shipping. After that,
the razors are just a few bucks a month. That's a $15 value for only five bucks.
There's no hidden fees, no commitments canceling. Any time you'd like,
you can only get this offer exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com slash burger that's
dollar shave
club.com/bar oh shit. Pro Flowers. This is the last one I'm going to read.
Then I'm gonna go back to the podcasts and I'll read these other three later,
plural pro flowers. Have you ever forgotten your anniversary?
If you're nodding. Yup. Um,
you're lying. What? Have you ever forgotten your anniversary? If you're not,
if you're not nodding yes, you're lying. The fuck are you talking about?
Well, I guess I've forgotten mining that I book shows not realizing it was my
anniversary. I don't think about my anniversary till it's coming up anyways.
You know that those people that are just hard to shop for like your wife for
your, your anniversary or your sister for her birthday. It's the worst thing.
Trying to get that perfect gift a, you know,
they'll try and get that gift a, you know, they'll like and be,
won't cost an arm and a leg. Well, I'm gonna make it easy for you.
Just get them a bunch of fucking flowers. It goes sweet art.
Thanks for being you pro flowers have a deli is my go to for flowers.
They're fresh priced right and our perfect gift for literally anyone pro
flowers. You've got to stop acting like this is the only thing you've got to do.
Pro Flowers is to perfect a cutera mall to something else that you get.
A woman wants something thoughtful and they definitely want flowers.
You have to fucking get them flowers, but she also got get something else.
I don't give a fuck if you go down and get them a zag nut bar.
The fact that you got in the car or you were in a grocery store and he's thought
about them and you get them flowers, Bam. That's it. All right.
That's it and I guess what about these flowers? They're fresh.
They're price right, and our perfect gift for literally anyone. They're fresh.
Yeah. They run off somebody freshly dug grave and they deliver.
They get delivered straight to your recipient's store.
How easy is that right now? Pro Flowers as a special offer for our listeners,
get $10 off your purchase of $29 or more.
This deal works on bestselling gifts like a hundred blooms, boot, k,
a dozen red roses,
or even there at total quality unique plant gifts to snag this great deal.
Just go to pro flowers.com and enter the code bar at checkout.
So right now get $10 off your first purchase of $29 or more it pro flowers.
But this deal definitely won't last long.
Just go to pro flowers.com and enter Promo Code Bar at checkout to get this
special deal. This is great too.
If you have someone in your life that's on the other side of the fucking
country, you know what I mean? Big Bank. Boom.
It's right there and it's like you thought about me smile.
Um, all right. Anyways, here we go. All right,
let's read some questions here for this week.
See if I can stop talking about that fucking golden state thing. Uh, hey bill,
would love if you would find it. I would love,
I would love it if you would find it to come back to Sweden.
Malmo gets boring. There's too few redheads to spend my money on here.
Thank you. All right. I feel like he was vaguely trashing me yet.
He likes my comedy. Um, I'm definitely going to be coming back to Sweden.
Last time I went through Europe,
I didn't do the Scandinavians countries.
What are the Scandinavian countries people come on? Norway, Sweden,
Denmark. I know there's one other one in there.
It's not Finland.
That's part of the Nordic countries that also include Scandinavia.
Yeah.
I can't even remember. It's been so long since I was there.
I learned that Scandinavia was like three countries and then those three
countries are part of the Nordic countries,
which included Finland and this little island just north of uh,
Great Britain. Right. Isn't it? Something like that.
I will definitely be back and I'll have a brand new, our few fucking blue eyed,
blonde haired cunts and a, we'll have a great time, uh,
from a lovely French lady.
Hey Bill. Uh, hello bones. Your uh,
I just wanted to say,
I just want to send a little message and hopefully have it heard that being a
video, very video graph for myself.
I immensely appreciate the graphic work and details and efforts of family.
I'll thank you. Such a great show on so many levels. That's it.
All the best to everyone involved with bill in general. And of course,
Bill himself a French fan fan from Patty. Hey,
guess what? French lady
Fam Della Francais, um, lady of the France, uh, of,
um, the show is actually the, the, the animators is Gaumont,
which is in France. All right. And then of course, you know,
then they farm it out to these people. Big Jump in, in Ottawa.
That's how it works. But you guys are part of the mix. And I'm,
what's great about France is if you use French animators and animation company
is you get a, the government gives a little bit of money. It makes it cheaper.
You know, it's a smart thing. It's like a Trump thing.
They try to bring fucking business, you know, into their country.
Like Trump says he wants to do as he walks away from the Paris agreement. Um,
it's just a hoax climate change, not global warming anymore.
It's climate change, jets, little change in the climate. Um,
I saw some lady on TV going like, you know, I,
I think it's good for this country that we do it.
And because we've always been a leader in, um, environmental issues.
Yes, we have been a leader fucking fucking it up the most as far as I can tell,
if I'm to believe what the scientists are saying. Oh, scientists,
their information. Anyways. Um, by the way,
thank you to everybody that's watching season two, the, uh,
people have been loving it and uh, you know, it's a ton of Goddamn works.
It thank God you guys enjoyed it, uh, or have been enjoying it.
Please tell more people to watch it. The more people you tell to watch it,
hopefully the more fans we get and then they'll let us do a season three.
Um, you know, and if not,
I'll just have all kinds of free time in my life.
It's kind of a win win for me either way.
People either I get to continue working with these great people doing this great
show or a, I'm going to become a hell of a drama. Um,
all right, well thank you so much and I can't wait to get back to, uh,
France at some point. Uh,
just gotta wait till the little one gets a little bit bigger. Um,
we're actually, I'm, I or I want to do, I was talking this to Nia.
I want to get like some sort of fucking, uh, you know,
French person over here, right. That can, you know,
help make my daughter's smart cause she's got to learn from somebody. I know.
I ain't gonna be me.
And as she feels to teach us in French and teaches us all French,
how great would that be? My little cutie pie be over in a France speak,
being fluent. Huh? I'm cute with that. But you know,
she's sitting up a by herself now. It's fucking amazing.
She has this look on her face. She's like proud of herself.
It's the cutest thing I've ever seen in my life. It's just the best.
I'm telling you. It's the best. There's no material and having a kid,
there really isn't, other than your fear that something gonna happen to them.
But I feel like that's been fucking done to death. You know what I mean?
Other than that, it's just, it's been fucking phenomenal. Um, okay.
Uh, F is for family. Hey Bill, I'm a big fan of your work, uh,
in from Puerto Rico. Oh,
help you top to see you perform some day here. Um,
I watched the second season of Memphis from family and is great.
Even better than the first one. Completely hilarious. Well,
take care and keep the good work. Keep up the good work. How would that work?
You know, Puerto Rico is like not a state, but it's one of those,
yet another place that we kind of just decided was ours. Um,
if I go on stage there too, I don't know. I went on stage in Singapore.
I didn't get caned. I'm sure I'll be all right in Puerto Rico.
I'd love to fucking go there. Bring my wife. She can go to the fucking beach,
you know. Oh, I'll be there with all the lovely ladies.
All those fucking j Lo's walking around. I think that would be, that. I could,
I could definitely be talked into that.
I go over there and tell my fucking shit jokes. I'm all right.
Can't stop smoking cigarettes. Uh,
all right. Get Job on new season.
Get job on the new season of F is for family.
I'm halfway through and it's hilarious.
I've been smoking for seven years now I'm 22 and I can't stop smoking.
Uh, it's really starting to affect my health and I'm sick of it.
I quit boozing and smoking weed,
but I've never been able to quit smoking cigarettes. All right.
And what the fuck? How do I help you do this? I tried to replace it with weed,
but it just makes me want to smoke a cigarette after alcohol gives me cravings
too. You used to smoke cigars, so maybe you've got some good tips.
I still smoke cigars to help me quit. By the way. She a,
you should come to Minneapolis soon and play a show.
Check out the new Vikings stadium. It's amazing. Um,
let's see you guys. Yeah. Near the twin stadium is amazing.
You guys are doing are right up there as the wilds.
The last time I went to a, I went to, what are you at at,
at the Timberwolves game?
Kevin Garnett was still there and you played in the target center and that was a
shit hole. Um, all right,
well they say quitting cigarettes is as hard as quitting heroin. So,
um, I dunno, I,
I would try to get professional help.
I am so happy I never started doing that. And, um,
you know, I don't, I like, I used to smoke cigars like, you know,
once every like four days or something like that. Now I smoke,
I'm like once every two weeks, sometimes three weeks.
And I really don't have the craving to do it.
I kind of wait for like the right time to do it.
Like riding in a car to go over to the NBA finals that felt like, yeah,
this is a cigar fucking moment. Um,
but the way I was doing it before, it was just like fucking, you know,
every guy, Dan couple of days, like, you know,
having a humor and all that type of stuff, you can really just, I dunno.
Um, I, I still think I smoked too many of them and, um,
yeah,
I don't eat right when I'm on the road and I drink too much when I'm on the road
and it's something I have a personally I have to stop doing that.
Um, I, and you know what it is, it's really,
I find it's just developing, I know people say this,
but it's just developing new habits. Like a, you know,
if you're eating shit food, you crave shit food.
If you're eating salads and good stuff, you crave that. And um,
I dunno, I'm a creature of habit. If it's just like every night, you know,
we're going out and we're having drinks after the show, it just became,
it just your body's like, oh, now we do this, it's in like this routine.
So you Kinda have to force yourself to break up your routine. Um,
and I think you just have to make a decision that you're going to be stronger
than it, you know, unless you have like some sort of, you know,
yeah.
Super Addictive, like personality, like those people.
And you've got to go into the doctor drew house or some shit like that. I mean,
I don't know what your deal is, but I would definitely,
I would seek professional help. Um, all right.
VIP airline. Hey Bill. That airline with the hot air
hostesses, um, exist. It only flies between Paris and New York. Oh,
I was talking about a VIP airline.
We don't have to go on with people that are going to take the shoes off and put
their feet up over the Goddamn,
um,
you know, sticking between your fucking, what do they do?
The sticking between your fucking arm rest and that type of thing.
Just those God damn animals. They should just have a first class one.
They should have animal airlines and then fucking raised right airlines.
So he's saying there is a VIP airline,
but it only flies between Paris and New York. It's only business class.
They give you iPods, feed you chef made food and plenty of good French wine.
The tickets aren't even that expensive. Um,
treat Nia to a holiday. Best from France. Well,
what's the name of the fucking airline?
You got to give me the name of the airline dude. Ah, now I gotta look it up. Oh,
hey. I gotta tell you I'd look up, you know. Well,
I got time to fucking do this with my internet even work fucking scam that that
is all right. Uh, the I P airline,
New York to Paris. Come on.
What do you say? Let's say American Airlines, New York to Paris flights,
Air France. The companion
discovered Paris was a unique for all business class airline. I found it.
Okay.
It's La, c o m p a g N, I e. Dot Com.
Um,
1800 bucks, dude. You said it was a thousand.
I want to see some pictures here. Plenty trip to Paris.
Oh Wow. Okay. I'm, I'm impressed with their little terminal there.
My company. No, dude, I live in La. I live in La,
so I'm not gonna fucking connect through New York.
I'm just going to say fuck it.
Use all my miles and uh, jump on a plane. Okay. For whatever in New York.
That'd be a nice thing to do. Maybe if I'm doing a Gig in New York,
then afterwards we can just go fly out a dad. It's a good idea. God dammit.
That's a good fucking idea. Who knows? Maybe it's,
I'll ask the wife about that one. You know what I mean? You know that works. Oh,
that was a question I wanted to ask Jerry. I forgot to do. I wanted to ask him,
do,
can you just come home with a new Porsche or do you have to clear it with your
wife? You know, can you get to a fucking like,
can you just look at it and be like, dude, I'm Jerry Seinfeld. You know,
look around your house. You like this, this, this, this echo echo.
Um, all right. Heart surgeon busted for filming. Me taking a piss.
What?
Bear dear Billy. Take tits. I got the fuck that mean.
That's hilarious. I heard this story on your podcast last week.
This fucking phone keeps vibrating. This whole podcast. The phone Fart,
Wayne. Oh, what the fuck is all of this stuff?
Oh, Jesus Christ. Alright, here we go.
I heard this story on your podcast last week about the Oxford students stabbing
her boyfriend in the leg with a butter knife and how she was led off easy
despite her psychotic actions.
I have a similar story that involved myself a little while ago.
I'm a musician and was playing a solo gig near some markets in the popular
popular part of Brisbane. Where the fuck is that? I've been there.
Oh, that's Australia. Ah, Australia. Huh? That was the next thing.
Let me sit calm. I went to the next, uh, page fucking hilarious.
During one of my breaks, I went to take a leak in the public amenities.
Uh,
I was doing my business in one of the stalls when suddenly I noticed an iPhone
slowly coming over the top of my stall to my left.
I can only see half of the phone, but could tell the camera was going.
Obviously it took me by surprise and for about two seconds my head went through
a does not compute mode. I was only halfway through taking a piss. I said,
what the fuck? Out Loud. When I heard the stall next to mine open very quickly,
I looked behind me and saw short, possibly Asian guy running.
I tried to stop mid Piss, very difficult, adjusted myself, quickly,
ran and ran out after him only to find hundreds of people through the markets.
I couldn't see him anywhere. I was infuriated. It was infuriating.
My first thought was, oh great,
now I'm going to be uploaded to some quote. I love public pissing.
Dot Khan porn site. Uh,
I was really fucking pissed off, no pun intended from this guy evidently,
but kind of glad I didn't catch it because I probably would have dragged him by
the balls to the police and then they would charge me for his salt.
I don't think you would because it's a guy to guy a physical confrontation and
on his phone there would be your Dick. Anyways,
a few days later I was telling my friend what had happened and he said that he
heard about an Asian German national being caught filming seven men in the
public toilets in the same area and he found the article online.
So it turns out this 26 year old guy's a trainee heart surgeon on holiday in
Australia celebrating his graduation from medical school. Here's the article.
What the fuck? Wait a minute. Wait a minute. Well,
at least he doesn't work on somebody fucking urinary tract him and he's,
he's, he's uh, he at least had enough discipline to be like, listen,
I can't be near the Dick area. I don't trust myself to,
he's up by the fucking hat. Um,
okay. This, this article is slowly but surely opening. What, what is the,
what is going on in the world?
The judge went easy on him and didn't record a conviction because of his
promising career. What the fuck?
I guess if you're a doctor you can get away with anything. What the fuck.
So just because you're an elite student in this world,
you get let off easy for doing really fucked up things.
Apparently none of the other men filmed or aware of what he was doing.
So I called the police in the area. He was caught.
They asked me to describe what I was wearing at the time, blah, blah, blah.
And said the phone was confiscated, the footage was deleted. I fucking hope so.
They also act. I was him saying that. I just gave it a great read,
so it sounded like me. If I could pat myself on the back.
They also asked if I wanted to press charges. I said, fuck yes.
The cop I spoke to said he would pay the pervert a visit very soon to lay the
charges as the guy was due to leave the country in two days.
I called back on the day he was supposed to leave the country,
but the cops said they wouldn't won't be pressing charges because they had
already been laid by the arresting officer and that the student had received a
conviction. Even though the article said he hadn't weird,
but apparently he will never be able to enter Australia again for the rest of
his life.
I just think it's so fucked up that these people can get away with such
disgraceful actions,
especially someone like this heart surgeon who could potentially be playing with
some poor guy's balls as he lays under the anesthetic.
I'd love to hear your thoughts. Well,
they kind of have the guy in check because heart surgery, you need other people.
Um, oh, here's the guy. German Torres
Ludi Tran was fine. 800 bucks sounds like about a hundred dollars a dick.
Okay.
After pleading guilty to several seven counts.
Oh seven counts, seven and 800 site. I just, I don't know,
but 115 [inaudible] yeah,
but on a 15 bucks a whack or something like that on a 12 bucks, I dunno.
A count of recording in breach of privacy.
A trainee heart surgery. Okay. This guy, 26, a German national,
Jesus Christ, even fucking Asians, if they go to Germany,
they becomes sex perverts. I thought it was just the Germans.
What is it with that country? They just ended the pea in, in the shit.
And what the fuck is going on over there? Um,
okay.
So he's fine. Uh, 800 bucks.
It's a pleading guilty to the Brisbane magistrates and Saturday on seven concert
recording and breach of privacy. The court heard.
Lee had been in Australia for a month to celebrate his recent graduation from
medical school when he was, when he filmed the naked men on Friday.
Lee Film seven men in the space of three hours by holding his iPhone over the
wall of the neighboring cubicle. None of the men realize they were being filmed,
but his behavior drew the attention of South Bank security.
Who contacted police. Lee was arrested.
The police found the video of the men on his phone acting magistrate Bob Blah.
Describe his ass actions. It's disgusting. The fences of disgusting.
The offenses are disgusting offenses involving a serious breach of the privacy
of other adult males.
I can only assume the offending was for sexual gratification purposes.
Um, Lee's lawyer, Kate McCarthy,
has said her client had been accepted into cardiology unit in Germany and would
fly home on January 12th is a very promising career ahead of him. She said,
she said her client was ashamed of his actions,
but asking that a conviction not be recorded against him because it could
jeopardize his career and ability to travel. Mr Schubert.
Finally $800 and did not record a conviction. Wow, man.
Uh, you know, that's fucked up. That's really fucked up.
Okay.
That's really fucked up. And am I crazy to think that because he's,
these actions are against men, you know,
some atmos do a, it's just not as serious. I don't think, you know,
I just think that's, I dunno either people like, Eh, you know,
they think it's funny. Like if this is the thing, if a,
if a woman told another woman that's some woman I guess was filming and they'd
be like, what the fuck am I banging away? Maybe because it was a woman though,
but last week was a woman she had and she stabbed the guy with the knife.
Okay.
Maybe it isn't any of these issues. Maybe this is just, if you're listening,
if you want to get away with shit and you don't want to be a banker or be the in
an insurance company, then I would say get into the,
have a promising medical career front of you.
Evidently that just absolves you of everything that's really upsetting.
Um, all right, let's,
let's you want to you and the only way to follow up that upsetting story is the
only thing I know that's more upsetting than somebody filming another man peeing
without him knowing is me reading out loud helix. Everybody. Hey Alex,
you're unique. Oh, you're a special fucking snowflake.
You don't walk like everybody else.
Talk like everybody else shared Jack our sleep like anyone else.
So why is your mattress one size fits all?
What army movie is that from your mother's, Oh, not here anymore.
I'm going to teach you how to walk, talk, show, share lock,
United States, Marine Corps. Um,
because a truly customized mattress will cost you five to 10,000 bucks until
now. Go to helix, Heloc, sleep.com.
Answer a few simple questions and they'll run a three d biomechanical model of
your body through the proprietary algorithms they developed with the help of the
world's leading irrigant comics and biomechanic experts.
Whatever the fuck that means, I think he just got cloned the result,
the most comfortable mattress you've ever slept on. Just ask your replacement.
I love sleeping on this mattress.
Helix customers report a 30% improvement overall sleep quality and for couples,
they customize each side of the mattress.
The beginning of the end of your relationship,
your mattress arrives at your door and about a week in shipping is 100% free.
That's why everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes,
they're all talking about helix sleep.
You have 100 nights to try it out and if you don't like it,
they'll pick it up for free and give you a whole 100% refund.
No questions asked.
Go to Helen's sleep.com/bar and get $50 off your order.
That's helix sleep.com/bar hey Helen's sleep.com/burb upside.
Man, you know something,
there's a better way for you to buy business travel, man.
It's called upside.com and if you want to get rid of the middle man, man,
every time you buy a trip at upside,
you'll save your company a ton of money and they'll give you an Amazon gift card
worth hundreds of dollars. Upsides,
able to do this because they bundle your fun flights and hotel together for one
low price. Bundled pricing saves money.
If you're a frequent business traveler,
your company saves a ton of money and you get thousands a year in gift cards
just for buying your air and hotel together at upside.
Plus you still get all your miles. I mean, they got everything in here,
but a hand job, if you're shopping for business,
you'd be crazy not to check out upside.com it takes three minutes to see how
much you can save by buying your flights and hotel together for one low price.
And right now when you use, when you use my name Bar,
you're guaranteed to get at least a $100 Amazon gift card for your first trip.
And you can buy a little $80 camera and go into a men's restroom as long as
you're in the medical field and film other guys peeing.
And evidently you'll be fine. That's my name.
[inaudible] to get at least a $100 Amazon gift card,
say big on travel and get a big gift card every trip. Uh,
I love upside.com. Evidently upside.com minimum purchase required.
See Site for complete details. Oh, there it is.
Minimum minimum purchase required. I was gonna say you can't just give,
get a fucking $150 flight and give a guy a hundred dollars gift card and you're
gonna, you're gonna go wander. All right.
stamps.com everybody's stamps saves you time and money,
which you can use to grow your business. You know,
or stab your boyfriend with a butter knife.
I mean you got all you all this time. Now I can mail any letter, any package,
just using my computer and printer and the mail man just comes and picks it up.
Avoid the hassle, man.
I go into the post office and mail everything from postcards to envelopes to
packages, domestic or international.
Create your stamps account in minutes online with no equipment to lease and no
longterm commitments. I use stamps.com anytime I'm selling my fucking, I don't,
I'm pouring myself out selling posters or whatever,
if I can figure out how to use it. So can you,
and right now you too can enjoy the stamps.com service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm
commitments. So go to stamps.com. Click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbarthatstampsdotcomandtuberstamps.com.
Never go to the post office again. That's it.
It's a fucking rap. Um, all right.
All right. So what do we got here? What do I got left to talk about? Um, oh,
how about the fucking Nashville predators making it a series winning game three.
What? I hope the Cavaliers do.
What I still believe the Cavaliers can do despite the fact.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm not gonna get back into that again. Um, predators, when game three,
I saw a little bit of it. I was working that night and uh,
I actually saw when they went ahead to one and then three one,
was that the game? I can't remember. Um, so here we go. I mean,
from what I've heard,
they've been out playing the penguins at at least two out of the three games.
So maybe they'll tie it up and maybe someone like myself will get what I want,
which is a nice seven game series. A nice classic. So, uh,
that games tonight, I will definitely be watching. And uh, this week, this week,
oh, Billy red face,
I want to be on Howard stern on Wednesday, Wednesday, Wednesday, Wednesday.
My triumphant return. I've not been on that show since I believe 2003.
I did it twice in one month. I thought I was an in guy in an,
I never got another invite. So I'm finally back.
You know, I'm site psych to finally come back, uh,
onto the show. So please listen on Wednesday.
Um, and that's it. That's the podcast. Thank you for listening and,
and really men, no joke. Thank you to everybody who's been watching.
F is for family, telling people about it.
Um,
and then also taking the time to let me know how much you're enjoying it. Yeah.
Uh,
it's just, it's, it's really been one of the great weeks in my life.
I have to be honest with you. So no jokes or anything.
Thank you guys for watching it. Uh,
please continue to tell people about it and um, cause we already have cease.
We know we want to do in season three.
We just have to wait for Netflix to give us the green light and they give us to
greenlight by you guys watching it and talking about it online,
which you guys are doing. So I can't thank you enough. And um, and that's it.
Thank you to everybody at cluster fest. I had a great time.
Thank you to the city of San Francisco. Uh,
thank you to the warriors for still playing in the Oracle, you know?
Yeah.
Great. Fucking old. Oh, you know what's funny,
when I did that Seinfeld interview, I s I jokingly said that this,
this venue feels like an old ABA arena and evidently the Old San Francisco
warriors used to play there. So I felt pretty good about calling that one.
Um, all right. [inaudible] you're overstaying your welcome. Okay.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll check in on you on Thursday and that's it.
Let's go calves. Come on, man.
If you beat the fucking warriors with all their cool drum malls that they added
all of that fucking Juggernaut of a Goddamn team walking around,
thumping themselves in the chest as if what they're doing. I've,
I've said this for fucking ever,
and I'll say the last time when you were a little kid on the playground and you
were choosing up teams, even little kids knew when it was getting to,
when it was not on, on how I this, this is not going to this,
there's no competition here. Even as kids, you knew this,
the warriors are doing right now,
they're doing something that even children know are wrong.
Even children would break that up. You know, I really think it is.
I think stern left the NBA. Maybe that's what it is.
Maybe he would have stepped in. Who knows?
I always thought that that guy was shady. Um, I do know this. Without a doubt,
Cleveland's going to win a fucking game because the NBA does not make money as
nearly as much money on a four game series versus five, six, seven.
So at some point,
I'm looking for them to fucking just start calling everything on the warriors.
But then again, I am a fucking conspiracy theory. Fucking freak. Um,
I don't know. I still feel like the cavs not played the best game yet.
All right. I'm going to say they're going to win game three. Fuck it.
I'm putting it out there. Alright, go fuck yourselves. I'll see you on Thursday.